Euron Greyjoy: After Aegon and his dragons
burned our last king, Harren the Black, and
broke our armies, the defeated ironborn chose
my ancestor, Vickon Greyjoy, as Lord of the
Iron Islands, not king.
The stories claimed that the Old Way died
with Harren the Black and his sons in Harrenhal.
Our ships and axes were no match for Aegon's
dragons, so our ancestors bent their steel
into fishhooks and our kingdom into villages
and started telling the red tales around the
fire of how we used to be strong and how one
day we would be so again.
Generations later, a young boy listened to
them.
Dalton Greyjoy, the wild young heir to Pyke,
was rowing at five and reaving at ten in the
Basilisk Isles with his uncle.
By fourteen, Dalton had sailed as far as Old
Ghis, fought in a dozen battles, and claimed
four salt wives.
In his fifteenth year, he avenged his uncle's
death in battle, but he took a dozen wounds
and emerged from the fight drenched head to
heel in blood.
From that day forth, men called him the Red
Kraken.
During the Dance of Dragons, the Red Kraken
picked the side that was fighting the Lannisters
and fell upon the Westerlands while the Lannisters
were off at war.
Casterly Rock itself proved too strong once
the lady of the castle barred its gates, but
the ironborn burned the Lannister fleet and
sacked Lannisport carrying off gold, grain,
and hundreds of women and girls, including
Lord Lannister's favorite mistress and all
his bastards.
The Red Kraken now ruled the Sunset Sea as
his forbears had, and his longship once again
brought the Old Way to the coast of Westeros.
But then the war ended, and the mainland armies
came home.
The Iron Throne commanded the Red Kraken to
stop reaving, and when he didn't, a mistress
opened his throat as he slept.
While his sons squabbled, the Lannisters sent
their soldiers to the Iron Islands.
Thousands of men, women, and children were
put to the sword, and scores of villages and
hundreds of longships were put to the torch.
The glorious return to the Old Way had lasted
two years.
Jaime: It should not be hard to recruit lords
into a war against an enemy known as "the
Mad King."
We can even understand the lords who chose
to honor their oaths and fight for him.
But the krakens of House Greyjoy sat out Robert's
Rebellion on Pyke with their tentacles up
their arse.
Euron: My father Quellon was old, and sitting
is what old people do best.
Well, second best.
He would have sat out the whole war if not
for my brother and me.
We convinced him that nobody would fear the
walls of the sea if we curled up by our fires
while others feasted on the spoils of the
Mad King.
So the old man creaked into his rusty armor
and set sail for the Reach only to be routed
by Tyrell longboats.
When my father sadly fell in battle, my older
brother Balon beat a tactical retreat to his
own inheritance as the new Lord of the Iron
Islands.
Jaime: I'd rather die in the Reach than live
on the Iron Islands.
Euron: The roses are prettier to pluck.
But my brother was getting old and felt that
longing to sit, and the Seastone Chair was
as good a place as any.
Within a few years, he realized that sitting
is only fun if everyone else has to stand.
He had the priest reforge...
No, that's not right.
They picked up sticks on the beach, wove them
into a new ancient driftwood crown, and declared
Balon the King of the Iron Islands.
Unfortunately for my brother, the other king
in Westeros, Robert Baratheon, was famously
bad at sharing, and his father-by-law and
Warden of the West, Tywin Lannister, had a
mighty fleet at Lannisport within striking
distance of the Iron Islands.
Jaime: Yes, you were very clever.
And how brave burning our ships at anchor
in the night.
Euron: They would have burned the same in
daylight.
Lions are lazy beasts.
You didn't rouse them till long after I set
fire to your proud mane.
I planned it all, you know?
My first torch took your father's flagship.
If it makes you feel better, we didn't loot
it.
Out of respect and time.
Jaime: I don't think I ever saw Robert happier
than the day he heard about the Greyjoy Rebellion.
He'd been king for a handful of years and
many handfuls of other things, and it was
clear to him and everyone else how ill-suited
he was to rule.
But battle, he could do.
Unfortunately, by the time we raised our army,
we seemed to be winning the war.
Balon's eldest son, your nephew, died trying
to storm Seagard, and his men were thrown
back into the arms of their Drowned God.
If we wanted battle, we'd have to hurry north
before the ironborn put down their own rebellion.
Euron: And we would have if I'd had my way.
Rebelling was a stupid idea.
Jaime: Never stopped your people before.
Euron: Before Balon put those sticks on his
head, I told him that if he wanted to rule
the Iron Islands, all he had to do was give
King Robert a tour of them.
Why waste our forces fighting a war we couldn't
win for a place our enemy wouldn't want?
With the Iron Fleet, we could reave not just
Westeros, but the rich lands beyond the Sunset
Sea.
But my brother was too attached to that Seastone
Chair.
He commanded me to sail the Iron Fleet against
Robert's navy before he could ferry his army
to Pyke.
Jaime: A navy commanded by Robert's younger
brother Stannis, most known for sitting in
a besieged castle eating dogs and horses.
Remind me, how did you fare against a man
who'd never commanded ships in battle?
Euron: Nearly too well.
Jaime: Stannis smashed your Iron Fleet at
Fair Isle.
Euron: After I sailed it into a strait, where
our numbers and the size of our ships would
work against us.
It took some doing to convince my men to rush
into such an obvious trap.
Stannis was not a subtle man.
Jaime: You would rather claim treason than
defeat?
Euron: Victory would have only delayed it.
We couldn't hold off Robert's forces forever,
but we could waste enough ironborn that we
wouldn't even fill our own islands after the
war.
I made sure the Silence escaped.
That was enough for me.
That, and watching your army smash my brother's
castle soon afterwards.
Jaime: Why didn't you just abandon him after
Fair Isle?
Why risk your precious life fighting for him
at Pyke?
Euron: I wanted to kill the best knights in
Westeros.
Jaime: You failed.
Euron: So did you.
I expected pursuit when I fled Pyke on the
Silence.
But I suppose you were too busy not punishing
my brother to not punish the man who burned
your father's fleet.
Theon Greyjoy: Where the North has its honor
and the South its chivalry, the Iron Islands
has its strength.
Yara Greyjoy: We call ourselves the "ironborn,"
and we are warriors feared throughout the
Seven Kingdoms.
Theon: Or so we used to be.
Unlike their mainland cousins, the First Men
of the Iron Islands never bowed to the Old
Gods.
Yara: Theirs was the Drowned God, who made
the ironborn to reave and sack and write their
names in salt, steel, and song, that his enemy,
the Storm God, could not wash away.
We raised our kings from our own ranks and
used beaten foes as thralls to work our mines
and farm our land.
Theon: Or as salt wives, if a woman was pretty
enough.
Such was the Old Way, and while we followed
it, we held sway wherever the waves were heard.
When Aegon came demanding fealty, King Harren
the Black ruled as far east as the Trident.
Yara: Other kings, like the Starks, could
kneel, but Harren was ironborn, and the ironborn
must be beaten.
In Harrenhal, he had the mightiest castle
in Westeros, and the army to defend it.
Theon: But Aegon did not intend a siege.
He mounted his dragon and roasted Harren and
all his sons in their tower, and the old way
with them.
Because of Harren's defiance, Aegon pushed
the Ironborn back to our islands and gave
the Riverlands to the Tullys.
But he did allow the ironborn to choose who
would lead them.
Yara: House Greyjoy had always been one of
the greatest houses of the Iron Islands.
We trace their descent from the Age of Heroes
and the legendary Grey King, who took a mermaid
to wife and made war upon the Storm God for
a thousand years.
Theon: Blessed by the Drowned God, the Grey
King fought and slew Nagga, the great Sea
Dragon, and took her fire for his own.
Yara: This history made our ancestor, Vickon
Greyjoy, the natural choice to lead the Ironborn
after Aegon's Conquest.
For three hundred years, House Greyjoy ruled
the Ironborn.
We style ourselves Lord of the Iron Islands,
King of Salt and Rock, Son of the Sea Wind,
Lord Reaper of Pyke.
Theon: In truth, we were thralls.
Our people still chanted "What is Dead May
Never Die," but the Old Way had died.
Yara: Until the Targaryens followed their
dragons into the grave, and our lord father,
Balon Greyjoy, rose against the new king,
Robert Baratheon.
Robb Stark: "Dark wings, dark words."
I was only a boy when the raven came to call
my father, Lord Eddard Stark, to another war.
Balon Greyjoy had raised the Iron Islands
in revolt and burned the Lannister fleet at
anchor.
King Robert Baratheon again needed his old
friend.
My mother, Catelyn, was not happy to lose
her lord husband to Robert again.
Six years before, he had left her to avenge
his father and brother against the Mad King.
But now he had sons and daughters of his own,
and, unspoken, another son who was not hers
from the last time he went to war.
My brother, Jon Snow.
But she knew that in marrying my father, she
had married the North.
We hold our honor and duty as dear as our
own gods.
When the time came, my father marched south
to restore peace and order to the realm.
My father always told me the Iron Islands
were a strange and dangerous place.
Its people, the ironborn, keep neither the
Old Gods of the Forest nor The Seven and despise
all honest toil.
Their ancestors ravaged the western shores,
and putting it to the torch, and their songs
still ring through the halls of the ironborn
while everywhere else they're whispered to
wayward children at bedtime.
Perhaps Lord Balon thought Westeros had not
healed from the war against the Mad King and
was as fragmented and suspicious as the ancient
kingdoms his forbears had terrorized.
Robert's navy corrected him at Fair Isle when
they smashed the proud Iron Fleet.
Robert and my father corrected him at Pyke
when they pulled down his towers and breached
his walls.
My father never liked to speak of his battles,
but, from other men, I learned what transpired.
Thoros of Myr was first through the breach
with his flaming sword.
Not far behind him was Jorah Mormont of Bear
Island, my father's bannerman who earned the
knighthood he would later shame, and lords
from every corner of the Seven Kingdoms.
All day through every passage of the castle,
they fought side by side.
My father with our ancestral sword Ice and
King Robert with his warhammer against a horde
of ax-wielding ironborn.
In the end, Lord Balon bent the knee.
King Robert generously allowed Lord Balon
to retain his title and castle.
The price of peace was custom.
The only son of Balon's to survive his foolish
rebellion would be taken as a hostage against
future treasons.
My father even volunteered to foster the boy
himself, I suspect to make Theon Greyjoy a
different man than his father, who would bring
honor and duty to the Iron Islands when he
returned as heir.
So my mother's silent fear came true, and
my father returned with another child.